foreign
Lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
hello
[Music]
you know what I don't like is when
[__] guys talk about 50 Cent the
rapper and they say 50 Cent why do they
do that why do white guys like with
[__] button-downs do that
know because I think it's [__] funny
I guess no I think sometimes think they
think that that's what it is it's so
it's it's it's uh mildly racist if they
think it's what it is then yeah it is
yeah actually you guys like 50 I'm a 50
Cent I like 50 Cent you know those guys
that like barbecues with open toe
[__] sandals they all always have uh
button-down shirts yeah that are blue a
shade of blue yeah one shade of blue or
another yeah no matter what yeah I know
yeah oh you already knew yeah forgive me
for [__] they get pink when they
drink yeah definitely they get like
lobstery yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure
[__] yeah I I try to brag but like my
[__] gets so crowded down there that one
time sounds like a brag is coming no
it's not a brag but one guy there was a
guy I was just sitting on a on a [__]
I was waiting I was waiting on a plane
and I was I was waiting on a plate I was
in the [__] terminal and I was
waiting delayed and dude this guy next
to me kept putting a [__] camera on
my head and I'm like what are you doing
dude I finally the first time I was like
get out you know what the [__] you know
and I can't be I must be crazy why would
a guy be putting a camera on my head
that's a great question yeah and and he
finally kept putting the camera on my
head and I go hey buddy what are you
doing and he goes whoa he's he got
scared and I was like shocked he was so
scared he said I'm sorry I thought you
were a tripod
um
and I said
oh yeah you know
so he was like I get it you're crowded
downstairs and I go and I was like oh so
you don't even know I was human that's
why I got scared when I started talking
he said yes
at the same time he said yeah because
tripods don't talk oh okay I don't
believe you that that happened guys try
to put cameras in my head all the
[__] time
just twisting it
that is so stupid wow
wow if a guy picks me up they instantly
think that guy's a cameraman
okay well no one ever picks you up
because what the [__] no one else picks
you up no one ever picks up an adult
male human my coffee's hot my coffee's
hot it's been awfully not come off
all right yeah my [__] coffee's hot
dude what the [__] dude
um
oh
[__] dude can I drink my coffee man okay
um so anyway
advisor okay so um [__] now I'm hot and
[__] oh good dude
um you know what you wanna know what
happened when I got here first of all I
should tell everybody what just happened
this is like Memento you're so out of
order right now start
at the right place and go do you want to
know what happened right before this yes
why is that like amento because you
start about your shoes or something
because it made me think of uh I was
thinking about that's why it's like
Memento yeah you started and then went
in another one in another Direction and
it was all out of order I go on crazy
cool tangents
so go ahead tell me what happened before
that
um so I we're on our way here right yeah
there's a good burrito place oh
I'm pissed already but I mentioned
burrito that you said burrito again dude
every single episode you've said the
word burrito at least once in the first
two minutes okay okay no not the first
one the second one I wanted to call the
last episode or the episode before that
the upswing of the burrito and you
didn't want to do that I wanted to call
both of them the upswing of the board
and those those words all together each
one of those words is fine but those
words together like just the aesthetic
the sound of that is [__] terrible
upswing of the burrito that's so bad and
I can't even believe you're my brother
and you would want that it would
definitely be a [__] great you're
telling me dude all right look if you
want to make a movie called The upswing
of the bridge starring Josh what's his
name in [__] Brolin no the other one
oh I want Josh no but the guy the bad
guy in the hot one of the Hulk movies
Josh it would be Josh Lucas yeah dude he
would be in the upswing of the burrito
no and the chick would be uh Cameron
Diaz and it would be in 2006. what's it
about like like me missing each other
and then meeting each other again and it
all took place outside of this [__]
Mexican restaurant wow okay just tagged
on like [__] yeah but that's what
they would do they would be like can we
make it a burrito can we make it a
Mexican can we involve Latina it's hot
can we love you know producers would do
that [__] okay
when your Lover's best friend becomes
your best friend's lover the upswing of
the burrito fall in love all over again
love it's tasty the the pro the problem
is is that ever I can't even really
think about what you're saying because
in the middle of it you said upswing of
the burrito again and it like it's like
nails on a chalkboard okay it makes me
[__] mad dude now that's some [__]
that you have that you have to do I'm
not saying it's not because I don't want
to have to do with it so stop all right
so look that's like the [__] how many
meters stripping stripping
stripping the sandstorm that would be so
bad dude no dude that's like the number
one strip no you know what's the number
one strip stripper song uh wanna [__]
you like animals
from the inside you're right you're
right or damn it
damn it
stamp tap tap
stand up the Portishead song
I mean I had no [__] idea what that
was and also what Porter said song
because that doesn't sound like any
importance well they all kind of sound
the same but this one goes I heard yes
she can't really thought it was until
right here
[Music]
so rude how close your hand is to my
face
also were you saying like don't
interrupt me is that what that was Yeah
well yeah here it comes so [__] rude
dude if I just close your mouth like
this and damn it no or or like a
lollipop Mr take me away yeah I know
well now we got to explain it okay so go
ahead that's the great thing to explain
Mr takeaway was a guy he's a Japanese
man who taught Spanish and very funny in
high school or high school now we're not
saying oh look all walks of life all
Races can teach whatever the [__] they
want equal opportunity we're all about
inclusion but look dude Mr take me was a
Japanese guy
she's good to bring up dude he's a
Japanese he's got I'm probably talking
about this on my pockets at some point
but this Japanese guy who [__] he
taught in Japan he's thick accent oh
yeah yeah I would say uh he yeah I mean
he would say welcome welcome to class I
mean like it was a trade like a Japanese
and you would be like
yeah and we were like it was very and I
remember it was so confusing and I
remember one time he was like these kid
the bad kids came into class and they
smelled of like drugs and [__] and
alcohol and he was going ah ah
and I was like what and he said and I
was like what are you saying and he said
smoking oh
but he would go what was the thing yeah
because yeah when you were talking no
look at his watch or whatever right okay
uh
okay
please like like you know how like in
between on a walkie-talkie it'll go he
would do that with his mouth though okay
[Music]
it was just a human walking that's right
that's right you don't even go dude he
was a human walking why would he go
because he was a human walkie-talkie
okay human walking talk that's it Mr
Tech made the human walkie-talkie that
sounds like a [__] uh movie that
what's his name who did a Isle of dogs
would do uh Wes Anderson yeah West
Anderson would do that uh uh Mr takamay
I love dogs yeah Mr takamay
the what is it the human walkie-talkie
would be made by the guy who did the
[__] stop saying the guy just said
Wes Anderson I forget what his [__]
name is
Anderson's name dude you don't know
anybody's name no that's not true Mr
take away
country
[Applause]
oh [__] balls of country man
oh [__] man
oh man this guy couldn't [__] be like
the sixth seed tennis in his [__] oh
dude every every every
color in this shot is a different shade
of the same color yeah lighter shade on
him on his skin the back the brick the
[__] uh couch his balls balls and
Country magazines wow dude Jesus this is
this is the cover of balls and country
man yeah all right cool next I mean not
next
Jonathan calling out of Fresno
California
Chris Adam missed the last time you came
here I'll ever come back but maybe not I
had to work of course the day you have a
show and telling my possible
uh anyways I need some advice so me my
wife
about our first baby should be popping
out any day now for sure hopefully soon
got a little girl on the way nice uh
question is
on the last of my last name
for you know you fellow Italians Chris
and Matt last name is Vietti I really
want to have a little boy yeah I
obviously don't know what the future
holds but
you know I'm thinking if I pop three
girls out that's matched for me I don't
know if if I want any more after that so
just want to see what you guys take on
it keep going for it until I pop out a
boy
three's too many so some more peek out
yes it's kind of pushing it but you know
maybe four I mean talking I'm talking to
it let me know what you guys think I
have five six you guys do love the Pod
and watch every week helps me get
through my day
after work forget about it which is what
I'm doing now so nice let me know guys
thanks uh cool well that's a I think
about that sometimes stop thinking about
it oh the life the family line the the
[__] Vibe of the family still goes if
you have a [__] [__] girl she's just
telling you you're wrong uh it's it's I
think we're past the stage of worrying
about if the name continues they do in
the tutors they do that a lot they want
the name to continue what are you
[__] exactly yeah what are you Henry
the 350th this isn't 14 45 it's [__]
2022 we don't need to worry about our
names continuing it's not a thing yeah
but you know what on the other day
at it you know what I mean Hey My My hey
I get it you know you want that name to
live on right well okay you want to have
a son of course but the name gets to
live on she can [__] combine her name
with whoever she finds a partner but
broads can't carry the name maybe she'll
be gay and they keep her last name like
it sounded like it [__] [__] out of
it kind of sick last name I like his
last name you want my [__] Mario
Andretti whatever the [__] his name is
you wanna [__] keep that name going
right why are you being a lot louder
when you do that because we're Italian
we're emotional you pop out a [__]
girl or two oh your namesake is gone
right right you want to [__] son
coming out of that [__]
what's that coming out right the worst
gynecologist on the face hey so what are
you here for you think you're pregnant
let's see spread them
looks like it's got somebody in there
so terrible hey congratulations you're
like four or five weeks you're like two
three weeks in there
now let's hope it's a boy so your
[__] husband's lineage could live on
right cause you know these broads they
don't carry the names hey they don't
carry nothing right you need a piano
getting upstairs who do you call anyway
take two of these and call me in the
morning thanks a lot smoking man I love
my [__] job telling the order of a
pizza pizza did I know I know a couple
who kept the female name
what and they named the child the female
they gave the child the female's last
name you just gotta be kidding me
[__] God
[Applause]
damn Tunas toadas the tutors the tutors
Henry the eight wow we started at Henry
then it was Henry the second
then it was the you know
there was tree Henry's doesn't know the
story at all
how was her three Henry's if it's Henry
VII because you any training and four
and five and six and you get to eight
and that one was the mother of that
[__] was crazy it was all that
bad in his [__] broads you know they
were having [__] women and [__] yeah
yeah yeah you got one kid he died of
like syphilis he got older okay said
case honestly okay Chris Evans call her
this guy's the [__] I'm watching since
day one big fan day one was two weeks
ago my question is about
[__] a roommate do you [__] your
remote oh my God thought of it right
then Chris Evans and Thor now had a baby
that can get complicated it
so sexy
hypothetically being sleeping with my
roommate and she's
become emotionally evolved despite
uh being forward about intentions
and
yeah
thanks guys being so casual Ford abood
intentions dude being so casual my
question is it had to be quiet because
his roommates in the other room no dude
she's sucking him while he's doing it
and he didn't want to you want her to
know that he's doing the video the
question is
about [__] your roommate so what's
the deal with that
um so while I'm talking about how much
is that guys I'm getting sucked by her
right now dude that's Bill Clinton neck
I was basically Bill Clinton you know
what he is honestly a question should
have been which Marvel Avenger am I
because he was in between Thor and also
Captain America he actually really was
um you're usually wrong but that was
right no not usually wrong
um so here's the thing about what this
guy's asking about here's the thing
about what this guy's saying he [__]
up so bad yeah yeah and everyone in the
entire [__] Universe knows that yeah
in the Marvel Universe apparently except
him what do you mean because that was
obviously a bad idea to do it so he did
it already he did it already Okay he
said what do you oh because she got
mostly involved yes people can get
mostly involved before they even [__]
but that was obviously gonna happen with
one of them one of them was obviously
gonna get more emotionally involved in
the other one right because of obvious
life living
because of obvious life living this was
obviously going to happen all you had to
do was look at obvious life livings of
everyone that's ever lived a life well
and you would know that some this is
gonna be a bad [__] idea I don't even
want to give him advice he [__] did
the dumb thing but guys are stupid
though dude because I agree if you're a
roommate and she's gonna be walking
around obviously in not many clothes
because they're roommates and she's got
to get ready and he's gonna catch a
glimpse of her [__] you know what I
mean walking by with the door open and
he's just gonna go like huh and then
it's going to one day just be so stupid
and drunk whatever you like [__] I'm
sorry you're having some boner and
you're cool but you're a [__] that is
so dumb no but here's the thing though
it happens all the time and somebody's
probably gonna wind up dead but the main
thing is you just basically have to not
ever [__] your roommate ever it's oh
unless you're prepared to move because
you've got to move now yeah and guess
what you gotta move no matter what you
gotta either move if you work out or
don't work out if you don't work out one
year has to move yep right obviously if
you do work out you still gotta move
because she's never gonna be happy with
the [__] place that you have because
it's probably too small and it was for
roommates exactly not for loving living
yes yes it's deeper and it's all good
but that's the truth so that is the
truth yeah so you [__] up honestly
shaving going to the witness protectors
program dude don't don't [__] ever
leave just leave leave
the country leave the country come to
America because you're obviously in
Canada
a boot dude that kind of the thickest
Canadian accent also the beard just so
Canadian yeah but um also work Carhartt
which is [__] super popular in Canada
up up super North he's so Canadian he
like carries around and acts in case he
needs to chop wood yeah and he never has
a shirt on even when it's snowing
but he has that hat on she's like the
guy from The Simpsons yeah yeah yeah
um all right so uh yeah dude you [__]
up but if the advice is what do you do
now
do you have two options one move but
that's the obvious option you're gonna
move two just be real about it be like I
think we made a mistake is there any way
we could go back to the way it was
before obviously the answer's gonna be
no but there's a slim chance it's yes
but those are your only two [__]
options you you did a bad bad bad
mistake Chris Isaac
baby did a bad bad thing isn't that that
Chris Isaac song baby so I think I was
singing it oh bad bad thing I think that
he also is too bad that we're not in
sci-fi movie because he could wipe her
memory and then just [__] walk around
and be like we didn't [__] yeah come the
Men in Black every song you sing is the
exact the note is exactly the same no
matter the Galaxy Defenders okay back
um so yeah dude you [__] up get out of
it unless you love her if you obviously
if you are into her then just continue
the relationship right yeah but you're
you made a really bad mistake not a bad
bad thing
yep that's good when I do that that is
one of the good things that song Chris
Isaac had two good songs and that's it
dude Wicked Game in that oh look at
things
[Laughter]
Bill Clinton
wow
the Oval Office no
no no no no no no no no
the bad bad thing every song is medley
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh [__] dude
wow
but I am yeah
you say Alabama yeah
same it's exactly the same Arkansas in
Alabama is exactly in the same
so rude what you did
Alabama that what's the end of the part
the end of the song where he just starts
talking about Arkansas he doesn't do
that he was completely making that Chris
Isaac does it no he doesn't at the end
of the game he just starts at the end he
just he just like kind of trails off and
it's the end of the song
oh yeah yeah yeah dude hi Matt and Chris
I love you and I love Calvin too okay I
am extremely embarrassed I'm one of my
early 30s and I still live at home with
my parents and younger brother the other
night I was in bed watching some
naughty videos
I had my airpods connected of course
what I was completely unaware of was
that my phone was also connected to the
Bluetooth speaker in my all caps parents
bathroom
I didn't know your phone could be
connected neither did I do two devices
at once but apparently it can crying
clown face my regular face oh regular
crying face uh my mom confronted me the
next day to ask if my phone was hooked
up to the speaker and I checked and
still unaware of the major atrocity said
oh yeah oops it didn't hit me until she
said I noticed it last night
shock face oh God I want to die I want
to fly to outer space and never return I
want to change my identity and only wear
wigs from now on what do I do do I leave
it at that do I confront her about what
exactly she heard please help shoot me
love you now just honestly this the
advice I have is you didn't do anything
wrong no you didn't you made a mistake
by having your parents hear that [__]
but you didn't mean to
um but like the whole shame of it is
like you don't need to feel that there's
a very human emotion but like you don't
need to feel that because honestly it's
just sex it's not even sex it's I mean
it's sex but it's like naughty videos
and you're a [__] grown-up you know
yeah she says she's 30 right yeah yeah
you know you're 30. in your 30s like
you're a full ass adult you can do
whatever the [__] your mom directly in
her eyes and say my bean needed
attention am I what you look at your mom
right in the eyes and you like say it
like Mr Mr Anderson in the [__]
Matrix okay my bean needed attention
what word are you saying being my being
needed you yeah what's that well it
looks like a bean on your body in
between your legs like a coffee bean
okay no no well
it looks like a lentil bean up top I
don't think it looks like it looks like
a coffee bean the actual thing looks
like a coffee bean but I'm saying oh oh
the lentil bean up top
lentil bean oh okay
there's a lentil being on top of a
coffee bean if you know what I'm cutting
there's a big coffee bean it's like a
Russian doll a bit of beans there's a
there's a big coffee bean but I'm saying
actual sized lentil being above the big
coffee bean that's the bean that needed
attention really because I got it hello
bean okay so what you need to do
is realize that your mom also needed to
attend to her being at some point uh
that everyone in the world attends to
their beans that's why in all the old
ass [__] religious texts it says
nobody is allowed God said nobody's
allowed to play with their beans yeah
okay it should have been everyone loved
you know it's okay to attend to your
beans
wow that's good the 11th commandment and
it's okay to attend to your beans you
shall always attend to your neighbors
beans all the Commandments have to do
with their neighbor you know yeah yeah I
know that's so weird just make sure you
are not hooked up to your neighbor's
Bluetooth as well yeah only be hooked up
to your own Bluetooth when you attend
when being attentive to your mean or
just attending to your beans right
I think I got the language right yeah I
mean it doesn't really matter because
it's not real but yeah
okay anyway okay just own it dude you're
[__] attended to your being and you
got caught I needed to lightly move my
being around also what's with the mom
yeah I noticed like what a dick dude
she's just she got all pent up she needs
to [__] hang with her being a little
bit dude you should send her the video
uh air drop the video to her and say
yeah being attendance is required yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's true being
attendance required comma mom yeah read
be in attendance in the email
and she sees this to other people and
gets she's just so bad with technology
oh no all right yeah for sure now a word
from our sponsor better help I've been
in therapy for
12 or 13 years now and it
quite literally saved my life I cannot
recommend it more I think everybody
should be in therapy and there's no
better way or easier way to do that than
through better help as the world's
largest therapy service better help has
matched three million people with
professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things are not clicking if you don't
like that therapist you can easily
switch to a new one anytime anytime you
want a new therapist you get one it
could not be simpler no waiting rooms no
traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
Lifeline that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash Lifeline here's what I
think about Elon Musk buying Twitter
okay
okay that's my take on okay why though
because I do the [__] [__] cares who
owns Twitter right right Elon Musk just
happens to be able to make a story or
[__] get all of a ton of attention
about whatever dude you gotta let if
Twitter already is a [__] Cesspool
you gotta let everybody on it if you're
gonna let anybody on it or make actual
strict rules where people like if Trump
can't be on Twitter then other there's
so many other people that shouldn't be
on Twitter that's the thing it's like if
there's gonna be a rule make it for
[__] everybody even the [__] even
people who aren't Donald Trump like
that's the thing the hippocrite the
hypocrisy the hypocrisy about Twitter is
that it definitely leans left and it
does extremely
um but it is a private company that's
just not no no I know that I know that
but so if there's some liberals own it
and they're like we don't want [__]
right-wing [__] on it then that's
their prerogative I know that I know
that I do know that but right now it's
bigger than than just a company it's the
way the world runs so it's changing I
know but you can just have an exception
for it's like this I know this I know
that you can't have just one company be
like no no you can't do that but every
other company can do whatever the [__]
they want I know that but I think that
this is what you're asking if if Elon
should buy it if he's going to buy it
what he should do and this is what you
should do if you have a big company like
this I think it's your responsibility to
make rules and make sure everybody
abides by it that's it because Trump got
kicked off for [__] that people are
doing all the time every day he's
already said he's gonna let Trump back
on and right I think about the whole
[__] thing all right cool so there's
the advice be the one that like goes
broke spend it on your boys yep that's
what MC Hammer did for whatever not to
that extent but that's what MC Hammer
yeah that is what he did he was like
people like go hammer go hammer go and
he went and now he's [__] broke dude
now he's gonna go get a loan yeah he
would perform at like you know a high
school graduation if you paid him wow
you know 2500 go hammer go hammer go go
go go go and demand to Wells Fargo to
ask for a loan that's what they mean all
right cool sweat coming on all over my
cheeks at a week stand uh that harder
than ever did before when they go Gotta
make time with the door and they go and
then when they were there
here we go instead of saying the RS like
he was Mexican the amount of sounds you
made yeah that go along with the amount
of words that's very strange you said
made so many sounds so few words here we
go and now see now it's my turn to talk
right so you talked for a while I let
you talk now it's my turn to talk
just keep doing it right so now the way
we're gonna do it is I'm gonna talk
right just a little bit and then you
talk again okay go ahead okay I forgot
what I'm gonna say go ahead
legit
[Music]
yeah that's legit okay
hey hey those legit no it would be like
it would be those Legit to Quit I I yeah
the slight difference it was legit those
legit that's the only word they would
change yeah those two I don't know legit
oh I know that I'm just saying what if
the song really was that in uh
dude it probably is didn't even try you
know all right dude what what is what is
here he's looking it up what's legit in
Spanish oh wow it's legit
oh my God
it's right there dude yeah
and then quit we don't know quit I don't
know probably like
doesn't have the same ring to it
doesn't have the same ring to it so bad
and I want you to stop
the greatest part about this podcast
that has ever happened dude and what's
interesting is that's true how bad I
want you to stop has to be the [__]
absolute title of this don't be don't
burn bridges yeah yeah don't I mean
there's also there's also there's also a
way to
make sure to oh my god dude
yeah yeah
foreign
my question is do you have people in
your life who are allowed to fart and
people who aren't what a great question
uh my buddies were over the other day
and one of them farted
and I was appalled and disgusted and
said no don't do that wow and he was
rightfully offended because apparently a
few minutes earlier our other buddy
farted and I giggled
I had to dig deep inside myself and
question why can't you and why can he
and why
um
and I can't find any explanation other
than you're just not that guy like you
just can't
and I proceeded to make a list of people
in my life who can and the list people
yeah I can't find any similarities she's
funny
um what's that about am I just being a
fart gatekeeper does it make sense
think about the people in your lives who
can and can't have fart rooms here's
what I think
no one can fart around me yeah don't not
no and I can also fart around everyone
that's how everyone feels but it's like
it's like you're on spit like you can
look at your own spit when someone else
spits it's like you [__] pig farting
it is because it leaves a [__] Trace
but it's like you know somebody farts
and it's like you're a [__]
[__] Pig like David Sullivan
farts so much you know I was just with a
mini fart yeah of course he did because
he's got that big [__] head I don't
like that and he's [__] gross and he
[__] wears shorts and he farts and
[__] you can't smell it
so I can't eat cheese man and then he
does anyway where's Savannah yeah you
pay the price we were in Savannah and he
was he was there in Savannah at the film
festival his film festival coincided
with Mike oh cool and he was there and
he was like yeah I'll get this without
cheese though oh wow and then the guy
left and I was like man you [__]
gotta eat cheese and like nah it makes
me fart man if I eat that special around
people I'll start farting immediately
man why does he act like he cares he
doesn't care that guy's a [__]
disgusting fart machine so dick he
doesn't my point is so dick he doesn't
eat cheese a lot when I'm around me but
I make him do it and then I tell him not
to fart because I want him that's
torturous but okay so here's where you
saw a movie
you've been bypassing eating cheese so
much and not farting but now you're
subjecting people around you to the
stench of your insides here's some
Parmesan eat it and fart your way out oh
I want to play a game
hahaha
[Music]
took so long to get to the joke you know
oh walks around if you're like oh okay
so the detectives later
I think I know what happens yeah is
Chris Rock for some reason
I don't know what happened Chris Rock
Okay so
I smell farts so Sam Jackson background
God damn farts no one
is allowed to fart around me I just
watched spiral okay
no one is allowed to fart around me no
one is allowed to burp her on me no one
is allowed to be [__] disgusting
around me without my Express
permission Moses [__] signed
contract saying it's okay I mean
permissions you know you need signed
permission to fart a [__] just keep
it walk out of the [__] room
walk out of the [__] room you're
gonna fart I won't
you won't but that's great you don't
it's gross your farts smell like [__]
death that's not true you just your
farts smell like decomposed corpses
after 30. I put Altoids up my butt okay
well they [__] don't work okay
none of this is true guys I do know what
she means though about how some people
are less gross when they fart and some
people are more even if they're the same
fart but for me it's a no-fart rule just
don't do it your house is in no fart
Zone unless it's you and I'm alone yeah
right right are you dude if I'm in a
room with somebody I don't [__] fart
no the other way around you no because
you've got to be honest when I am in a
room and I fart I'm being me I'm giving
you all of me I'm not holding back no
one wants respectful that's not
respectful no one wants all of you they
go I go you're welcome that's yeah then
that's come on you want me to not be me
you're a psychopath
you're straight up psychopath who was
the person that called in we just kind
of started to talk about oh yeah I think
that there's a no farts on it that's
really I really like that you have a
list of people who can and can't fart
yeah and I think that you should brief
people on who can and can't yeah yeah
totally but like and then when they say
why not me you say honestly because I
think you're more disgusting than the
other guy yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're the kind of guy I don't
want to smell their insides yeah you're
gross you gross me out already yeah and
then when you fart it puts you over the
[__] Edge because you're disgusting
you [__] pig so dick so I think but
also some parts sound wet some people do
well once oh come on I don't do white
ones my shit's dry but I don't do wet
ones but sometimes you hear like their
cheeks
you know and it's disgusting as [__]
yeah it's so gross and then dude have
you ever farted but and then [__] by
mistake not me I never honestly I
actually never have done that I've heard
people talk about me too Eric Griffin
talked about it last night oh well then
now that is gross yep he farted dude and
he didn't know any any [__] when he took
a Steppy [__]
[Laughter]
and then like get up and be like oh I
bet when he tells the story he describes
the farts 100 yeah yeah yeah because
that's his signature move all right
first time I met him I was astonished at
how many times he did this I know yeah I
know it's disgusting one-on-one yeah I
was farting [__] coming everything
was that dude with privates everything
he was in a [__] comedy movie I
looked at the other day so far in a
comedy movie he lost in a coyote movie
comedy movie I looked at yeah like an
old lady says it serious I looked at one
of my programs and Mad Max was in it was
it the drinking movie yep no I don't
know what's that well I don't know
what's the movie oh not the drinking
movie no uh it was a foreign movie okay
okay well he's farming what's the name
of the movie I don't know
okay well that you brought up something
that we can't even discuss no we can't
but I do love mads he's another guy
who's funny and he doesn't seem like he
is yeah that's true he was on a flight
once he also he also commits
so hard to the roles that he's playing I
know like he's in that [__] movie uh
that Nicholas winding record movie that
nobody saw uh the ones in black and
white
he plays like a crazy crazy Viking and
he uh uh uh anyway he's just like it's
like the bloodiest [__] movie ever uh
what the [__] is that in that movie dude
uh Rio
read out the cartoon yeah yeah no Ice
Age Ice Age yeah so um no but I I saw he
was on a plane of mine oh he was on a
plane with me and he he was sitting like
maybe one behind me and I would I I
would look back and like that's the
[__] guy then I didn't really know
his name you know years ago I was like
that's a [__] guy that's the bad guy
in the James Bond movie all right yeah
yeah and he was reading a script and he
was just like reading the script like
this and the light was on I mean it was
so cinematic it was a nighttime flight
and he was just like turning it over and
I was like he's so I mean maybe this is
[__] me but like you know succumbing
to Hollywood but I was like dude he's so
an evil villain yeah he's yeah totally I
mean he's a great actor he got huge he
was always a popular actor but he what
made him huge is that show he was on was
playing Hannibal Lecter oh yeah that's
right playing Hannibal Lecter probably
such a goofy show but yeah also was he
the lead of the [__] Pusher movies is
that was his like first [__] I don't
know what that is uh all right well
since nobody knows anything in his I
mean this is literally yeah
we show him on the screen right now and
they'd be like oh yeah that guy
true he's super super super
handsome in a weird way how much when he
has sex dude it's so quick Valhalla
Rising and this is how he has an orgasm
he goes a kiss
and that's it that's the whole orgasm
that's the whole orgasm but then
in a few minutes like in the shower
whoever he had sex with hears him with
the door closed she hears him off like
in the bathroom just go
okay what's he doing he's just like
getting the energy out
pull your ass down or take it off pause
it I don't like when hair peeks out of
the Hat that's why it's fine but if it's
like that like like an actual garden
growing under his hat take it off it's
actually never it looks like Chia Pet
like he just [__] puts the hat on and
then smears that [__] stuff and then
Waters it and then and then the Hat
stays there and it grows out a little
bit like this is the time lapse like
that right but he's trying to also hide
his Chia Pet because it's poking out
from underneath right also pubes
pubes for sure 100 cubes on his head
yeah like there should be a dick on his
forehead yeah and there is and that's
why he's wearing a hacking he's hiding
it 100 all right cool and so he figures
as you both actually um have been for a
long time Matt obviously got to you a
little late in the game Chris been a
long time fan of you for a long [__]
time through thick and thin baby
um so I need some advice
so my name is River and that's pretty
different nickname at least around here
you know like I'm thankful for it my
whole life I'm 24. I have dealt with uh
you know like the jokes on my name so
um which is cool like I don't care
because
kindergarten you know
um of course words that they use like
you know Lake ocean all that good [__]
so I messed with this girl on a dating
app the other night I know stupid
shouldn't be all night and she said nice
to meet you Pond and I go oh nice
pretty big talk from somebody with a
normal name what's your name was Shelby
good millions of them and so she uh then
she responded back with wow are you
victim blaming it's not my fault that my
parents name me that and I said no it's
not victim blaming if I'm saying it in a
way of I I know it's not your fault but
you have a normal last name so know your
normal ass name place in life you know
so okay I'm not asking uh I'm not asking
advice on how to deal with that I just
want funnier ways to respond back to
people that give me those kindergarten
uh nicknames like you know just the ones
that are just so on the nose and easy to
grab for it's a good question but uh
yeah thanks guys dude I think you should
say first of all I think he dealt with
it really well he did but he should say
actually that's funny because I wish we
were near a body of water so I could
drown you right now you know and kill
you in a river or anywhere or if they
say hi Pond you say interesting I wish
we were near a pond it's funny you bring
that up because I would love to drown
you
yeah for so long yes yeah and then well
no that's on social media what you what
you but yeah oh Ray actually we're
saying no but what you should do is
honestly
right
all of the things that people say all
the time on cards okay and always have
them with you good and then you show
them and then when they when they say
one just go like this
yep yep yep
pick it out and go like this
it says do you know how many times
someone has called me Pond they would
feel
that would be good so molded dude yeah
yeah that would be so cold-busted man
yeah it's true that would be so moted
but also when you start like start with
a number that's already high don't start
at one because then when you pull it out
like don't start from scratch when you
make that list because then when
somebody does it and you're like you
know how many times people have called
me Pond and then they read it and it
says like two no no no but just no but
just say something that people often say
to me is oh so there's no counter I'll
hand it to it right okay yeah it would
be so molded yeah what is molded it's
called busted oh cold busted okay one
time when um
um one time when I was in second grade
uh
Mrs Beatty I I remember her yeah I had
her she was a frumpy fat one nope oh
then I don't know her don't okay so now
that was Miss banaxis okay but no but so
now you're being worse than I was in the
beginning I was just like calling it
back okay but that's fine but maybe
they're dead now who's Mrs Beatty Mrs
Beatty Beatty this is [__] Mrs Beatty
was great he [__] beat me off you
know what I'm saying no nope absolutely
not man okay okay okay
wonderful woman okay second grade
teacher and I was yeah I didn't have her
I had Miss Caldwell
I remember her match venon had her she
was pretty oh maybe it's not she
probably got hit on she was really old
right Mrs Caldwell now she was very
young oh damn I I don't know okay so
anyway um
Rasheed I remember Rasheed he was pretty
funny yeah yeah he was [__] funny I
wonder what he's doing now
um he was saying something to miss
Beauty and Miss Beatty was like Rasheed
no hold on a second and hold on a second
and and Rasheed said oh Miss Betty
that's called busted and then miss
Beatty said Rasheed if you don't get out
of my face I'm gonna go bust it all over
you whoa yeah dude and it was so
hilarious dude I laughed so hard as you
can imagine I mean even in second grade
he knew it was funny oh me yeah I had
never heard kobasa before in my life so
I was laughing I was having a conniption
thing I mean man it was so funny oh baby
that's called busted
receipt if you don't get it in my face
I'm gonna go bust it all over the place
so she was I'm gonna go bust it so that
would be a version of clapping back not
the best idea in 2015 right exactly
because she because Rasheed could have
went right to the and she said the
teacher said but she was gonna bust on
my face then she's gone forever
Witnesses I was a witness so I would
have been like she didn't actually say
that okay the principle but she did say
that she didn't know all over the place
kobach said all over the place get
caught doing something you shouldn't
while you're convicted guilty of
um cold
it yeah they used it differently though
back then cobusted meant like [__] up
not that wait wait hold it deliver
insulted that's what it was delivered
insult attempt to highlight and accuracy
I'm trying to raise money for college
your mom goes to college did that's what
it was yeah right okay yeah hell yeah
dude Russian astronaut in space
allegedly scammed the Japanese woman
into paying for his return trip to Earth
vowing to marry her once he landed this
is from Vice believing this man would be
her future fiancee the woman paid him
about 4.4 million yen about thirty
thousand dollars in five installments
from August 19th to September 5th the
Japanese newspaper yummy reported but
when his demands continued the woman
grew suspicious of his intent and
reported him to the police who are
investigating the case as a romance scam
local media reported a romance scam
Intergalactic romance scam dude dumb
Intergalactic romance scam
romance scam Intergalactic I
I this is the thing dude scams are are
shitty you can prey on people and make
them scams like I watch this HBO Max
[__] documentary on scammers and
these guys really go out of their way to
make people feel like you know
comfortable and good at giving money and
[__] like that those people uh you know
those people deserve to pay some sort of
penalty or whatever this guy yeah
figured it out she should pay some
penalty for being so [__] dim hello I
am in space I need to get home I need
you know rubles or whatever the [__] the
Aruba is whatever the [__] Russian
money is yeah and four four points oh
it's Japanese she was in Japan
oh my god dude yeah like imagine this
guy just like
If I Only Had thirty thousand dollars
and also how did he find this woman like
yeah here's the thing about B the
scammers whatever obviously they're
[__] villains that's [__] service
up there but the people who get scammed
was it on Zoom yeah the don't get
scammed dude oh dude dumb ass [__] dude
it was the zoom with the space
background
just like this he's just like this doing
it like this like like
having the wallet flow so you can't see
his hands yeah he's really just some in
Moscow somewhere you know what I mean oh
my God they saw early and I need five
grand
I need five grand alien allergic to Yen
please need rubles need anything you
need yeah I mean the advice here is any
flat bottom line anybody who emails you
that you don't know no you do not give
them anything information further
further than that the advice is never
trust somebody on the internet period
yeah even someone you do know because it
might not be them yeah yeah yeah yeah
and if they want money no
this is crazy dude how are the cops
going to get him though in outer space
it's hard it's hard so you enter
Galactic please
yeah he's gonna get away dude
[__] it
so [__] stupid
[Applause]
I mean it's taking it's taking so long
because the space is slow that's the
bullet
my question is so my fiance we actually
just got engaged a couple weeks ago but
the other day I noticed that my
toothbrush was wet oh we've been
together for almost seven years whoa and
I noticed my toothbrush was wet and I
was like I didn't brush my teeth so I
went up to him and I was like did you
use my toothbrush because he didn't have
his and he was like yeah I yeah
that's disgusting right and he's like no
it's not
so I guess my question is like maybe
Chris would you do that with Kristen or
is that disgusting or is it normal
because we've been together for so long
should I not be grossed out by that
I think it's gross but whatever let me
know what y'all think it it's the bane
of my existence right now why because I
and let me tell you why all right I I
like my [__] you know me right okay my
shit's my [__] okay if you want to drink
some of my drink it's yours now okay let
me just chill have my [__] there's very
few things that you get to just kind of
experience in your own body and brushing
your teeth that's one of them okay so
I've noticed the same thing my
toothbrush wet I walk over I'm like no
this has been like two years now I'm
like Chris did you use my toothbrush and
she's like
oh yeah and I'm like oh okay well that's
disgusting so what where's your
toothbrush she's like I couldn't find it
and then I go look for two minutes and I
find it right so look a little bit
harder for your toothbrush also don't
lose a toothbrush also if you lost your
toothbrush walk around with a dirty
mouth that's your Penance here's the
other thing too I bought and I'm not
joking 20 toothbrushes I bought 20
toothbrushes this way oh Kristen these
gold ones are mine about them all the
same the gold ones are mine and you have
your blue one okay okay
dude fire a bunch of blue ones or no no
I got her she has a blue one and I got
her she's also there's also like a green
one and a red one and she wants to use
it and like dude she'll just like
willy-nilly take one of the gold ones
and bring it in the shower which is fine
because I'm like okay hers is in the
shower mine's out here and then I gotta
bring mine in the shower I bring mine in
the shower and then I put it down like
wait a minute which one's mine the Gold
ones are mine dude it's so gross to use
someone else's toothbrush and let me
tell you why not because of the brushing
the teeth because some people brush
their tongue
dude that's disgusting but you [__]
you're Mack it all the time on it hang
on if you're macking if you're [__]
got your Mac on and your Mac in Non-Stop
with your mouth on the other one macking
away what the [__] is the difference
between that and sharing a toothbrush
just illness the staleness okay fresh
ass toothpaste on it
um Mackin is about fresh kissing mix of
saliva yeah beautiful temperature yeah
you know my temperature in my mouth is
meeting your temperature of your mouth
okay this is love making okay okay using
a stale toothbrush that someone else
brushed their [__] tongue on or got
the [__]
lettuce out of their teeth come on with
that but it's the realness and that's
why you don't like it because you don't
like the realness which is what it
actually is which is what I'm talking
about but like who cares you're not
you're not seeing it happen like I don't
know that [__] only grosses me out when
like I'm visualizing it or see it
everyone who cares walking through the
door that's who cares
a marching band of people who care
I don't like that all right well it's
the truth I like that you did that
that's fine
what's this we're opening the garage
somebody drove out with a bunch of
people
it's just disgusting you don't think
it's disgusting and here's the other
thing if they actually don't I really
just I don't yeah if I was gonna pick
somebody
to do this with it would be Kristen of
course exactly which is why it's not
gross it's still gross it's not gross
dude
that's not gross she should divorce you
that you think it's gross it means you
don't love her if you loved her you
wouldn't [__] care dude does she care
it's yours no cause she actually loves
you
[Music]
you're not gonna say something
I'll adjust you yeah uh no I just I
don't I don't think it's gross and if
you think it's gross I think that's
weird that's just my take on it dude I
don't know what to say it's like you're
macking away you Mack all the time on
each other's mouths like who [__]
cares
also how annoying is it to
me getting all the toothbrushes and then
her still using for my tooth that's
that's a bit like is she trying to I
mean it's a little bit yeah it's like
that's like gangster [__] yeah that is
actually it's pretty baller to be like
yeah I'm gonna use the gold ones how
many gold toothbrushes around my
bathroom right now for real they're all
I mean I'll take a picture of it and
I'll send it in is there a way to put
like a label on it like a tape with a
letter on it frankly I don't think that
that would matter yeah but we do have a
label maker yeah you have a label maker
try it out dude okay I'll try it out and
same advice for uh this woman but it
sounds like he gets the idea now like I
would imagine that if you call your
partner out on it for doing it that they
don't like it that they would stop
obviously Christian's such a [__]
hard ass baller doesn't want to do that
this woman's husband might actually
respect her wishes and stop so maybe you
don't even need advice time you even
have a purple phone case
so I mean blending into your shirt might
as well put it in the center there so we
can see it on the screen
I mean QVC QVC we have got a beautiful
purple case let me just show the metal
show it to you here look it's absolutely
gorgeous isn't it hold it a little bit
so it more reflected away for there we
go oh now I get why they do that because
anyway it moves around look at that now
you've got grease stains in the middle
that's from his thumb okay no it's on my
fingers that's from your fingers right
there it's absolutely beautiful look at
that the way you type it you could type
on that that way you can type on the
other way and you'd be so not true you
know but it is absolutely gorgeous it is
coming right now if you buy one purple
case you will get a purple velor shirt
you will get this as supplies last we
only have how many do we have Phil
he's saying we only have a hundred left
we're gonna dock it down we want him to
fly but they're honestly they're going a
little too quick so we're gonna dock
them down we're gonna make them you can
get now you can get these you can get
another version of this
you can get another version of this for
probably a hundred and ten dollars this
is a better version
and we are not gonna give it to you for
a hundred dollars [__] screaming dude
just absolutely outright screaming
here's here's the thing if you want this
for 100 you go to them right Phil you
can go to we can't say the competitors
names but you go we are not going to
give it to you for a hundred dollars we
are not going to give it to you for
ninety dollars we are not going to give
it to you for eighty dollars what we are
not going to give it to you today right
now for seventy dollars
we are not going to give it to you for
sixty dollars we could give it to you
for fifty dollars but I'm feeling
generous we are not going to give it
three minutes
we are not going to give it to you for
forty dollars or thirty dollars today
only today while supplies last and I
don't know like Phil's telling me not to
do it we are going to give it to you for
four
payments
of 12 cents
and they're gone they're gone just like
that so long to get to the end yeah with
the purple velor shirt also he's you
have been doing you yeah how could you
say who when I say you pointing at you
yeah I thought you're talking about me
he I'm like he who he is me laughing you
wow wow [__] wow he who you okay uh
so you've been doing that yeah for can't
even tell you how long 23 years can't
even tell you how long probably 23 or
something like that more maybe 25 years
we've got I would just pick up stuff
around the house look at these glasses
okay and we've got Reese we have these
we and we're gonna get we're gonna give
them where we can't give them we're
gonna practically give them away
to uh yeah you can get this green wall
right now
40 easy payments of two cents well
this is not even worth it you know
that's 80 cents
say postage would cost way more yeah
posts goes away more honestly
uh so you can check on postage I have a
question for Chris how do I use a napkin
um where's my mouth
how did you become so sick with it well
I mean
oh wow you know just so that was the
best submission we ever gotten and
because of the chocolate on his face it
was so quick you know what was good
about it sounded like Chris cut his ass
off because it went too long right
like that wasn't the end of his video
that was the end of this oh really oh
dude
how to get too sick with it
Let's Play It Again look at his slovenly
I have a question for Chris Chris
um
how did you become so sick with it
thanks oh even better
first take us for our time first off he
started wiping his face when he had [__]
all over it what do you mean that's how
you started oh that's how I started me
it's like step one or step one when you
when it looks like you have dookie on
your mouth yeah yeah yeah wow dude so
that's number one yeah I mean dude
didn't give it that guy doesn't give a
[__] honestly how sexy is that guy in a
relationship for real because he so
doesn't give a [__] I mean zero percent
sexy okay if anyone was going in to kiss
that guy no when he had this [__] on his
face but the attitude about it is that
he did the video and thought and
obviously saw he's not blind because
he's driving he wanted it like he
thought it was funny that's why I don't
know okay then never mind you know he
thought it was being funny all right
okay but he still has his question he's
pretty sick with it already you think so
I mean you he's asking you I mean I
probably don't want to hang out with a
guy like that but he's pretty sick with
it okay because he's already he doesn't
give a [__] that's what makes you say
these two things that he's already sick
with it eh and that you wouldn't want to
hang out with him well because I don't
want to hang out with a guy who thinks
it's good to have [__] stuff all over
his face that's disgusting to me okay
period for any amount of time yes and
then uh he's already sick with it
because he doesn't give a [__] what
people think obviously okay because now
he's on you know hundreds of millions of
people are going to see this yes
billions yes by the way subscribe to the
channel we need to bring break 596 this
is a conspiracy super cold sooner or
later even I who never believed
anything's a conspiracy will start to
think this is a concern neither do I do
it but I'm starting to be like okay man
maybe we're a little bit Alex Jones in
this [__] the girlfriend just quit and
the guy just became friends with me so
now we're friends but then the mom of
the girl has been like spying on us and
showing her daughter hey they're like
flirting and hanging out 24 7. I could
care less like I literally don't care to
be friends with him I'm just friends
with him and that's hilarious like I
don't hang out like alone with him yeah
and so
basically
so she's been messaging me saying I'm
shady and to never talk to them again
and the mom she doesn't like her
boyfriend having friends at all like
she's in control of him but anyway
um I just want advice on how to uh like
do I
stop being friends with him
or do I just say [__] it and just lean
into it
you know and just say like
I don't care what she says and just
because I don't like that she can
control his life you know
um anyway yeah that's my question uh
I love you guys bye oh sweetie there's
the two options just [__] blocker and
then do whatever you want and who cares
about this [__] that's the third
option that's cool go to HR Dude tell if
you all work together you and somebody's
making it uncomfortable for you you can
go [__] tell them dude yeah they're
kind of like the neighbor calling the
cops okay but I mean yeah option two is
[__]
spit all over his [__] oh my God don't
do that 100 don't do that why not dude
you want troubles let's make waves baby
[Music]
that's the Rock Away lean back dude I
tell you what man that's like Dude if
you're gonna make my life difficult at
least I'm gonna come dude forget it like
that's so annoying oh well you know what
I'm gonna do if you're gonna keep
telling me that I'm trouble I'm gonna
turn around in front of your boyfriend
and show you what trouble is rank
oh dude
do the Rockaway Lean Back Lean Back
that's her afterwards wiping up okay
okay that's so annoying dude people are
so annoying no sure that is extremely uh
particularly annoying
um block that [__] idiot and never
ever think about her again
and [__] the mom the mom is the most
depressing [__] the husband of the mom
dude oh the mom is the most depressing
human alive you really do it where's
your husband at show up at Target while
he's getting shipped for the family wow
[Laughter]
so uncomfortable to get ahead that way
young
get in there dude why lean back
[Music]